please welcome my friend ted danson
ted and i actually know each other
because we made a movie in
alaska um during winter
and like lived on an ice floe for three
months together it's called big miracle
i remember that movie by the way we all
got in a kind of people mover there are
about 10 of us or something that decided
to go
and
everyone was very protective of you and
kind of encircling you uh so that we
could move through the crowds and all
that and i remember in my mind going
this is really necessary and coming out
of the film
you were mobbed by you know
half of alaska showed up um so anyway
well i mean it must be like everywhere
you go
i mean literally it's a pun intended
everybody knows your name um
do you
like does everyone bring cheers up to
you when they see like because it's
always different projects but is cheers
like the most evergreen well cheers is
the you know the reason why we're here
talking everything i've done in my
career
uh is because of cheers um
but um yeah i'd have to say um
walking through an airport is where i
get a sense of where my career is you
can kind of tell you know who's coming
up to say thank you for such and such or
i saw you and such and such
usually i get um
now i get middle-aged women coming up to
me and saying
my grandmother and i watched you on
cheers
it's like oh
wow good perspective thank you
well we both sort of grown up in front
and with everybody so
um
and you and mary
um i i
your love story inspires me to no end
you appear like one of those couples
that's like still hot
for each other
just so in love so funny best friends
like
do you remember
because you really are a couple goals
you and mary steen virgin do you
remember like the first moment that you
fell in love with her
um i
you know i was such a hot mess right
before i met mary we made a film
together called pontiac moon but both of
us came into that film
saying to ourselves well obviously i
will mess up any relationship i'm in
clearly i'm not relationship material
and uh
so we weren't looking for you know our
our radar wasn't up um
and we became friends and noticed that
while shooting you know
if i got to lunch late and i didn't get
to sit next to her i was a little upset
and then we took a
a canoe ride
this was up in mendocino on the big
river and we had this beautiful canoe
with an outrigger and
we went up with some other folks who
dropped away after two or three hours
and mary kept wanting to go around the
corner to see
what was next and we were gone four
hours and by the time we came back
i'd say both of us were in love
oh my gosh
[Music]
you